dans une lettre publiée lundi avec la
présidente de la délégation au droits
des femmes Dominique Verrien et les
membres de la délégation nous appelons
le président de la République à
maintenir la civise monsieur le ministre
ma question est simple et appelle une
réponse claire comptez-vous maintenir la
civise si oui sous quelle
formere la parole
monsieur ministre
déléguéteparole du
gouvernement merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Annique billon je
vous chercher du regard merci soyez
assurés évidemment il y aura une suite
aux travaux de la cvise évidemment la
première ministre réunit sous son
autorité aura lieu le le 20 novembre
prochain un comité interministériel à
l'enfance qui va permettre de colliger
de compiler beaucoup de données certains
et un grand nombre d'entre eux vous
l'avez dit 30000 témoignages d'enfance
n'est pas rien réunis par la civise
structure que je connais bien parce que
j'étais ministre en charge de la
question de la protection de l'enfance
lorsque la civise a été créée et je
connais je reconnais le travail
fondamental de cette de cette structure
c'est une structure qui a été crée pour
3 ans vous l'avez dit dans votre
question et se pose la question de ce
qu'il va advenir maintenant de quels
outils avons-nous besoin de quel type de
commission faut-il aller vers une forme
de C vis 2 faut-il revoir ou amplifier
les choses soyez assuré puisque vous
l'avez dit vous-même c'est l'engagement
c'est la grande cause du président de la
République c'est l'engagement de ce
gouvernement de la première ministre
parce que les chiffres sont terrifiants
ce que vous avez rappelé et ils sont
avérés un enfant toutes les 3 minutes et
victimes d'inceste d'agression sexuelle
de violence sexuelle dans notre pays
quand on dit ça on a tous des h cœur on
a même tous franchement envie de vomir
et de crier mais comme on est ici en
responsabilité au lieu de crier et de
vomir et d'avoir des h le curs on a la
capacité d'agir et pour agir on a besoin
des acteurs on a besoin du travail de
terrain on a besoin des professionnels
donc encore une fois les arbitrages
seront donnés dans quelques jours je
comprends les mois qui peut euh vous
avoir saisi en tant Commission en charge
de de l'égalité femmes hommes je crois
au Sénat ou des droits des femmes mais
soyez assurés que l'ambition qui était
la NRE il y a 3 ans elle est encore plus
vive
aujourd'hui madame
billon merci monsieur le ministre dans
votre réponse vous dites il y aura une
suite pour moi j'attendais la civise va
se poursuivre ou ne va pas se poursuivre
je voudrais vous dire qu'une assemblée
ou une institution elle doit toujours
être incarnée pour garantir son
efficacité nous en savons quelque chose
au Sénat le juge Édouard Durand avec son
expertise sa détermination ses
convictions démr qu'il était l'homme de
la situation la civice ne peut se passer
du juge Édouard
Duran